[Musique]
merci Bruno bin de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de la Vienne rattaché au groupe
les républicains et vice-président de la
commission des finances on va longuement
parler du Congrès des mères qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui dans quelques instants mais
d'abord un mot on a vu l'actualité du
côté d'Israël avec un un accord qui
serait proche pour la libération d'otage
en en échange d'une trêve ce soir sera
projeter au Sénat le film des attaque
terroriste du Hamas Roger kucci qui est
le président du groupe d'AM d'amitié
France Israël pardon a invité tous les
sénateurs à assister à cette projection
est-ce que vous irez j'y serai j'y serai
parce que c'est important de savoir
c'est important de connaître l'état
d'Israël a été attaqué il n'y a pas
d'autrees terme le 7 octobre par une
organisation terroriste donc il faut
comprendre les choses puisque
potentiellement nous sommes tous exposés
à cette
situation et donc c'est il faut
connaître parce que les enjeux du du
Proche Orient du Moyen-Orient ça fait
près d'un siècle qu'on en parle je crois
qu'il n'y a pas 40 solution une fois
qu'on a condamné évidemment le
terrorisme une fois qu'on a compris
comment il était éventuellement financé
c'est très important
euh la seule solution et c'est celle que
j'ai déjà eu à à défendre à la tribune
du Sénat c'est une solution à deux états
un État d'Israël dont on garantit la
sécurité et puis un de Palestine avec
des
institutions élues démocratiquement
installé et qui ne soi pas auain du
ramas qui est une organisation
terroriste vous redoutez de de voir ces
images qui sont très
dures la guerre existe sur ce monde il
faut en avoir conscience il faut savoir
l'affronter il faut
connaître et donc je serai ce soir au
côté de Roger
carucci une autre actualité on l'a vu là
aussi dans le journal c'est la suite de
la faire Joël guerot sénateur mise en
examen Gérard Larché lui demande on la
vue de se mettre en retrait de ses
fonctions parlementaires il est membre
du bureau il est vice-président de la
commission des affaires étrangères
est-ce que pour vous Joël garot doit
aller plus loin et démissionner j'ai pas
rentrer dans une discussion ou un débat
d'abord parce que je n'ai pas vocation à
commenter les propos du président
Larcher ces propos sont de bon sens pour
le reste il y a enquête judiciaire et
donc c'est à l'enquête J et à ceux qui
on ont la responsabilité de dire ce qui
s'est passé mais les propos du président
du Sénat sont comme toujours de bon sens
on va parler du Congrès des Maires il
s'ouvre aujourd'hui avec des élus qui
réclament plus de liberté d'action des
maires qui exercent leur mandat dans un
contexte difficile du notamment à la à
la hausse des incivilités et des
agressions on va en parler avec notre
journaliste audre vetas qui nous
[Musique]
rejoint
bonjour are bonjour bonjourre et parmi
les interrogations des maires et les
demandes des Mar il y a la question du
statut de l'élu et le Sénat a des pistes
pour améliorer ce statut de l'élu et les
détails dans la première partie d'un
rapport flash oui un rapport
transpartisan de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales porté par la
centriste Françoise Gatel le LR François
bonhomme et le socialiste Éric kerouche
pour tenter d'endiguer la crise de
l'engagement les acteurs préconisent
dans un premier volet d'augmenter les
indemnités des maires et de leurs
adjoints alors je vous ai prés je vais
vous présenter quelques exemples
d'indemnité euh un maire par exemple
d'une commune de moins de 500 habitants
va gagner 1041 € maximum par mois quand
c'est une commune de
3499 habitants pour pas dire 3500 parce
qu'après il y a des seuils ce sera une
indemnité de 2108 € pour les adjoints
c'est presque trois fois moins écouter
euh le président euh de l'Association
des mères de France
il est absolument anormal que plus de la
moitié des maires de France perdent de
l'argent en devenant maire parce que
c'est la réalité beaucoup cumulent avec
un job notamment dans les petites
communes qui reprent le tissu
majoritaire des communes de France et
l'indemnité elle est de inférieure au
SMIC nettement inférieure au SMIC et
c'est pas normal et aujourd'hui il
faudrait qu'un maire qui a une fonction
exécutive une responsabilité civile
politique et pénale et la capacité et et
et un revenu de au moins de cadres
moyens quoi enfin c'est c'est c'est ne
soit pas perdant notez qu'on parle
d'indemnité et pas de rémunération on va
y revenir et en fait ça se détermine
selon le nombre d'administrés et pas
selon la charge de travail moyenne peu
importe la taille de la commune un maire
consacre près de 32 heures par semaine à
son mandat les auteurs du rapport
préconisent donc de réfléchir à une
corrélation entre le temps passer par
l'élu et le niveau d'indemnité mais le
passage à la pratique pourrait prendre
du temps alors il propose à cour court
terme d'indexer au moins l'indemnité sur
l'inflation dès le 1er janvier prochain
l'autre piste c'est de créer une
dotation destiné à compenser les tâches
réalisées par les maires au nom de
l'État l'état civil les élections et les
missions de police judiciaire écoutez
am il exerce des compétences de l'État
qui lui ont pas été transféré c'estàd
qu'ils sont inhérents on va prendre
l'état civil on va prendre l'urbanisme
on va prendre l'organisation des
élections et nous nous sommes sur une
pour que l'État effectivement ou la
nation ne se contente pas de rendre des
hommages réguliers aux élus en disant
vous êtes formidable vous êtes pas assez
nombreux on voilà mais que l'État
affirme que comme il a besoin des
préfets des sous-préfets il a besoin des
élus locaux l'État devrait
contribuer peut-être pour toutes les
strates de communes enfin on en
discute un pourcentage des indemnités
globales
versé et Audra parmi les autres mesures
il y a aussi des rappels au droit oui
avec quelque chose de stupéfiant il y a
3 ans le Parlement avait voté pour qu'un
maire en situation de handicap puisse
cumuler son allocation adulte handicapé
avec son indemnité d'élu et bien le déc
décret d'application je vais y arriver
n'a toujours pas été publié et enfin un
point qui concerne l'articulation avec
la vie professionnelle car de nombreux
élus travaillent à côté de leur mandat
et bien pour eux les sénateurs demandent
à ce qu'une autorisation d'absence dans
le cadre de leur mandat puisse être
rémunéré à la hauteur de deux fois le
SMIC alors Bruno Belin l'un des auteurs
le sénateur Éric kerouche proposait même
de créer un CDD pour les maires est-ce
qu'il aurait fallu aller jusque là et
est-ce que les préconisations du rapport
vont assez loin selon vous là il
faudrait qu'on ait toute la matinée pour
parler de tous les sujets que vous venez
d'évoquer parce que le système est
foncièrement injuste injuste et
insuffisant injuste parce
que quand vous êtes maire d'une
commune peu de population vous vous avez
peu de service pas de directeur de
cabinet pas de directeur des services
techniques et bien souvent j'ai connu
cette situation comme maire du village
où je suis toujours élu un peu moins de
1000 habitants le maire fait tout y
compris la cantine quand vous êtes maire
d'une ville d'une agglomération ou d'une
grande ville vous avez des services qui
vous accompagnent on a bien vu le
tableau que vous avez montré une
décoréation terrible entre effectivement
le nombre d'habitants la responsabilité
et
l'indemnité il y a aussi évidemment le
temps donné quand vous avez en milieu
rural d' agriculteur le temps qu'il est
à la commune ou le temps qu'il sert sa
commune effectivement il ne peut pas
faire son travail quand vous êtes
profession libérale ce qui est mon cas
quand vous êtes effectivement pris par
votre mandat vous n'avez pas les
rémunérations de que votre emploi permet
la question de la rémunération qui est
évoquée par notre collègue Erric
kerouche elle semble intéressante à
priori c'est-à-dire parce que c'est
toujours la question de qui paye si on
donne une do ation comme c'est évoqué à
moment donné supplémentaire parce que
responsabilité des communes sur
effectivement état civil police
judiciaire contrôle de l'obligation de
scolarisation si on donne une dotation
c'est quand même le budget communal qui
va au sein du conseil municipal décider
des indemnités et on a toujours en
France c'est un sujet un peu tabou on
n'osera pas prendre l'indemnité maximum
on l'a bien vu par le passé où des fois
les maires prennent que la moitié les
adjoints prennent 10 % parce que c'est
le budget communal donc est-ce qu'on
doit avoir une rémunération qui vient de
l'État et là se pose la question que qui
dit rémunération dit contrôle de celui
qui vous rémunère or évidemment les
collectivités s'administrent librement
et on peut pas avoir l'État qui contrôle
les Maes sur l'effectivité ou la
présence de leur donc ça peut paraître
une bonne idée en tout cas c'est un des
vrais sujets la
l'indemnisation des élus en
France les moyens qui leur sont apportés
eu mais c'est toute la question des
budgets communaux aujourd'hui qui sont
en grande difficulté oui parce qu'on a
parlé d'indemnité maximum tout à l'heure
les maires ils hésite à prendre ses
indemnités maximumes bien sûr c'est
c'est courant enfin moi j'étais dans un
conseil municipal il y a quelques jours
du côté de mirbaau le maire racontait
que il avait baissé son indemnité de
fonction parce que aussi pour les
communes ça a des charges l'URSAF voilà
et que évidemment vous pouvez pas le le
l'enveloppe qui est alloué au budget
communal bah celle que vous consacrez
aux indemnités de fonction elle n'est
pas utilisée pour autre chose vous
pourriez prendre aussi les frais de
déplacement pas aucun élu dans ces
communes le font vous pourriez prendre
des frais de garde si vos enfants sont
gardés B que vous occupez vos
responsabilités tout ça les élus en font
l'impasse parce que c'est le budget
communal évidemment qui est impacté dans
ces cas-là c'est toujours la question de
qui paye les frais de déplacement qui
sont évoqués dans le rapport euh les
rapporteurs proposent de les de
rémunérer parce que en effet les élus ne
ne ne les prennent pas peut-être une
autre question sur les conseillers
municipaux qui sont pour la plupart
bénévoles on voit qu'en France il y a de
plus en plus de de conseils municipaux
qui ne sont pas complets qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour susciter des
vocations là je crois que c'est autre
chose que aller au sur la question de
l'indemnité c'est euh permettre à une
commune de se projeter d'avoir des
projets euh d'avoir de mener
effectivement aujourd'hi les les les
élus ils sont évidemment un contraintte
de est-ce qu'on va arriver à boucler le
budget là on va rentrer début d'année
dans les question budgétairees est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire c'est très
frustrant quand vous êtes élu vous
rentrez dans une équipe municipale au
moment des élections avec plein de
bonnes idées on va faire ça voà on va
pouvoir développer tel projet tel projet
puis on se rend compte qu'effectivement
l'équation financière fait qu'on a des
difficultés et donc ça peut créer des
découragements aussi bien chez les
maires il faut qu'on leur permette de se
projeter et donc qu'on les accompagne
aussi bien sur les dotations état et
puis d'autres collectivités on a bien
des lois de programmation pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour le
ministère des Affaires de affaires
militaires on a des lois de
programmation pour le ministère de la
Justice est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir une
loi de programmation pour les
collectivités locales ou à 3 ans par
exemple on voit comment ils peuvent se
projeter financièrement porter des
projets c'est ça qui a envie les élus
c'est pouvoir sur leur territoire porter
des projets pour le bien vivre de leurs
habitants mais c'est un serpent de mer
cette histoire de loi de programmation
il me semble qu'il en avait des
questions chez vous dans la Vienne lors
du congrès des départements ça remonte
que les collectivités territoriales
puissent se projeter on vous parlait des
départements je pourrais vous en parler
longuement parce que quand j'entends le
reportage tout à l'heure sur la
protection de l'enfance là encore on va
donner des sujets que j'ai évoqué 10
fois y compris ici on va donner des
allocations au moment du passage à la
majorité qui a un vrai problème pour les
enfants relevant de la protection
d'enfance mais la question c'est de
savoir qui paye si c'est le département
qui a la compétence protection de
l'enfance oui mais les départements ont
plus de ressources les DMTO sont en
train de s'effondrer il y a plus de
fiscalité les les les les droit de
mutation s'effondre les la fiscalité
n'existe plus les départements ne sont
plus en capacité et là on est en train
de charger encore la barque donc c'est
ça qui effectivement peut euh mettre en
colère ou inquiéter les élus et en tout
cas parfois les décourager mais moi je
suis convaincu euh qu'il faut qu'ils
aient qu'ils soient porteur d'espérance
de projet et c'est ça qu'il faut surtout
leur donner en moyen de de faire on va
continuer à parler de ces sujets merci
Audrey à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
on va parler des des mesures prises en
faveur des maires après les émeutes de
cet été ce sera à suivre dans le club on
continue à parler de de ce congrès des
MRES c'est aussi l'actualité dans votre
département de la Vienne Bruno Bellin où
on va retrouver Baptiste bise bonjour
Baptiste merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeur adjoint de la Nouvelle
République et de Centre Presse dans la
Vienne et Baptiste vous allez nous
parler d'un sujet évidemment qui
concerne de près les maires des maires
ont été agressés en fin de semaine
dernière dans le département de la vien
oui le même jour vendredi deux maires de
petite commune de la Vienne ont été
agressés dans l'exercice de de leur
fonction des faits qui ont ému les élus
qui étaient réunis le lendemain samedi à
l'assemblée générale des maires ruraux
du département alors on parle en effet
de village de quelques centaines
d'habitants où les maires sont en
première ligne pour régler les litige du
quotidien et gérer les réactions parfois
hostiles de leurs administrés à verrière
dans le sud de la VI le maire raconte
avoir été agossé agressé par le
responsable des ateliers municipaux
qu'il voulait convoquer à un entretien
avec ses adjoints il a littéralement
explosé dit-il en confiant avoir eu la
peur de sa vie une explosion de colère
des objets qui volent dans l'atelier des
menaces mais pas d'agression physique
l'employé municipal qui ni les fait a
été interpellé par les gendarmes et
placé en garde à vue un peu plus tard ce
même vendredi dans le secteur de Loudin
dont le secteur dont le sénateur Bruno
Belin est aussi un élu local le maire de
saint-clairire a été agressé à son tour
dans la soirée de ce vendredi il a été
pris à parti par un automobiliste qui a
pris la fuite le maire l'avait
simplement interpellé parce qu'il venit
de griller il venait de griller un feu
rouge pédagogique l'homme est sorti de
sa voiture lui a donné un coup de point
le maire est choqué nous sommes devenus
de la cher à canon dit-il si ces
agressions restent plutôt rares dans
notre paisible Poitou elles se sont
quand même multiplié ces derniers mois
il y a pas très longtemps en octobre
dans le bourg de vouiller à l'ouest de
Poitier le directeur général des
services de la mairie a été frappé par
un parent d'élèves parce qu'il lui avait
demandé de ne pas se garer dans la
devant la devant l'école pour des
raisons de sécurité après l'attentat
d'aras alors le président du conseil
départemental de la Vienne Alain Pichon
a adressé un courrier au ministre de
l'Intérieur dimanche soir pour attirer
son attention sur l'inquiétude
grandissante face à l'augmentation de
ses atteintes et de ses intimidations il
demande à géralde d'armanin de prendre
de toute urgence écrit-il les mesures
qui s'imposent je m'adresse donc à Bruno
Belin qui a longtemps été maire de la
commune rurale de montsurguen et qui
occuper lui aussi ses fonctions de
président du conseil départemental de la
Vienne avant son élection au Sénat
quelle mesure m le gouvernement peut-il
prendre faut-il faire évoluer la
législation pour condamner plus
sévèrement les agressions de personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité public et
puis plus largement comment répondre à
la crise civique et à la violence dans
la société bonjour Baptiste bise fait
plaisir de de vous voir sur ce plateau
alors effectivement les faits tous les
faits de violent sont inadmissibles Mo
j'ai eu la chance quand je n'ai jamais
bientôt 40 ans de mandat local j'ai
jamais été confronté à cette réalité ni
insulte ni de de
violence on a deux choses d'abord quelle
est la réponse en terme de sanction
euh j'entends prison prison ferme on va
pas mettre tout le monde en prison ça
serait un peu compliqué déjà on manque
de place dans ce pays et
puis le message est peut-être pas le bon
par contre je suis je me demande si on
peut pas aller vers des sanction
administrative c'est-à-dire avoir une
autorité qui est capable dans l'immédiat
de sanctionner sur un certain nombre
de de possibilités très pratiques
suspension automatique du permis de
conduire suspension du permis de chasser
interdiction de passer tout examen
euh retrait d'agrément si à un moment
donné vous êtes dans une situation
effectivement de de dépendance
administrative vous pouvez pas être en
contestation en révolte contre
l'autorité administrative la plus proche
la plus connue la plus que celle du
maire et à côté se dire je vais
revendiquer des droits que
l'administration peut m'apporter et donc
il y a peut-être des sanctions
administratives immédiates à la main des
préfets qui
permettront de faire comprendre que
effectivement c'est un acte de haute
portée que s'agresser que d'agresser un
maire puis moi je crois un vrai sujet de
Fond cher Baptiste c'est il faut qu'on
revienne aux fondamentaux quand j'étais
gamin le maire de la commune où j'ai
grandi Maurice so je me rappelle encore
de son nom ça remonte à plus de 60 ans
ben on lui disait bonjour On le
respectait on savait que c'était le
maire faut peut-être qu'on commence à
l'école à remettre ce qu'on appelait
nous de l'instruction civique mais
peut-être tout simplement expliquer que
oui la France est un pays démocratique
est un grand pays qui vit parce qu'il a
des institutions et que ces institutions
bien il faut les respecter et que ça
commence effectivement à ce niveau-là
David lnard il nous disait hier à votre
place que ces agressions de él elles
sont le signe de la décivilisation de
notre pays vous diriez la même chose il
y a une hérisation aussi c'est vrai
qu'on peut employer des mots très fort
il y a eu une évolution que j'ai que
j'ai bien vu depuis 20 ans exemple les
réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux et
les comptes anonymes des réseaux sociaux
vous avez un trou dans la route dans une
rue dans un village vous avez tout de
suite la photo qui est mise sur tel ou
tel réseaux sociaux avec le commentaire
le plus désobligeant comme quoi le maère
é un bon à rien et qui ferait mieux de
se 'occuper de ses trou que voilà ça on
le vide tous tous les jours tous tous
les jours enfin on le voit bien avec des
comptes anonymes sur X sur Facebook ou
autres ça c'est terrible comme agression
aussi et donc oui on a eu cette
hystérisation qui s'est développé depuis
peut-être deux décennies que j'ai pas
connu quand que je ne connaissais pas
quand je j'ai eu la chance d'être élu
maire qui n'existait pas il y avait pas
ces sujets de de violence on voit bien
que ça s'est développé depuis d'années
on a un contexte terrible le maire est
aussi peut-être celui qui est le seul en
première ligne parce que il est le le
représentant le plus visible partout et
à un moment donné où il y a retrait de
beaucoup de de fonction bah finalement
celui qu'on connaît et qu'on trouve au
coin de la rue c'est le maire Baptiste
oui non je je je je vois bien
effectivement ça répond à la question
mais à la deuxième question sur comment
répondre répondre à la crise civique
vous dites il faudrait commencer par
dire bonjour Monsieur le Maire dans la
rue que que peut l'État et que peut le
législateur à répondre à la crise
civique c'est-à-dire effectivement
comment on va trouver des élus locaux en
2026 c'est ça la question cher Baptiste
aussi aussi parce que c'est vrai qu'il y
a aussi un déficit d'évocation ou ouais
il y a une crise terrible d'évocation
toutes les semaines je suis dans les
conseils municipaux je pense qu'on aura
des maires je suis pas sûr qu'on aura
des équipes complètes parce qu'il va
falloir compléter les équipes et ça ça
passe par la possibilité aux équipes
municipales aux maires de se projeter ça
passe par la le fait d'avoir des
compétences parce que aujourd'hui si
effectivement les commune ne servent à
rien ça va être difficile d'aller
chercher des candidats pour remplir les
conseils municipaux enfin vous allez
chercher des enfants de cœur qui vont
servir dans des églises qui vont fermer
donc il faut qu'on leur donne des
responsabilités faut qu'on leur donne de
la matière faut qu'on leur dise voilà
vous allez pouvoir vous occuper de ça
vous allez avoir les responsabilités les
moyens et la possibilité de vous
projeter de porter des projets ça moi
j'y crois fancièrement c'est ce que
demandent les élus à tout niveaux et
donc il faut que les communes retrouve
des responsabilités retrouve les moyens
d'exister de se développer on a des
sujets très simples qui interrogent les
élus partout dans le leur département
plui voilà on perd les les les les
moyens de de construire sur nos communes
avec le zan c'est ces sujetsl euh
effectivement il faut qu'on donne aux
communes les moyens d'exister dans les
les les les poids qu'il y a sur les MRES
il y a une enquête du svipof qui a été
publiée hier il y a évidemment le fait
qu'ils sont victime de violence il y a
la question du fait qu'ils se sonent
empêchés d'agir par l'État mais la
première cause de leur malêtre c'est les
attentes trop fortes de leurs
concitoyens est-ce que vous comprenez ce
sentiment il y a une impatience il y a
une impatience il y a un problème il
faut qu'il soit mais c'est parce que on
est tout on est encore dans un monde de
l'immédiaté qui s'est créé avec les
réseaux sociaux avec le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a plus on attend plus
la réponse à un courrier il faut qu'on
ait dans la foulée le le SMS ou la photo
de la Lettre pour répondre ça on l'a
vécu tout doit être dans l'immédiaté et
donc vous avez une impatience générale
quand les choses ne vont pas assez vite
ce qui crée effectivement soit des
frustrations soit de l'énervement et
donc voilà faut
peut-être retrouver raison sur la
gestion du
temps merci Baptiste merci Baptiste
merci vousciav tu es avec nous la Une de
La Nouvelle République et au lien en
Touren le ventourne c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup Baptiste
bise d'avoir été avec nous ce matin vous
êtes vice-président de la commission des
finances Bruno Belin le Sénat qui entame
jeudi l'examen du budget est-ce qu'il
faut apporter des réponses financières
au maire David Lisnard dit qu'ils sont
sous perfusion d'un état malade que
l'État soit pas en bonne santé oui ça je
peux le rapporteur général Jean-François
Husson nous en a fait la présentation
bien évidemment on a bien compris que le
budget de l'État France est en mauvaise
santé donc là il faut qu'on ait deux
trois choses bien en tête dans les
années à venir qu'on arrête avec la
dette parce que quand on voit qu'on paye
remboursement de la dette 46 milliards
c'est plus que le budget de la
gendarmerie de la police et de la
justice réunie donc faut arrêter avec la
dette pas de dépenses nouvelles faut
avoir conscience aussi qu'un moment
donné on est sur un plafond et puis ce
qui est sans doute le plus important la
fonction publique voir comment elle doit
être répartie utilisée parce que là
aussi c'est des fois au détriment des
territoires et de la ruralité c'està
dire il faut baisser le nombre de
fonctionnaires il faut organiser
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire non j'ai pas
dit alors vous savez moi je je suis
parti je fais partie des gens qui
demandent des instituteurs sur leur
territoire qui demandent des gendarmes
dans la gendarmerie euh mais qui veulent
des soignants dans les
hôpitaux l'hôpital où du territoire où
je suis élu quand vous regardez la masse
salariale il y a plus du tiers qui n'est
pas du personnel soignant ça interroge
donc c'est mieux utiliser l'argent
public donc c'est un vrai sujet en tout
cas
euh là où 100 % des enseignants doivent
être devant des élèves euh dans dans
dans des classe et la question
effectivement des personnels soignant ou
non soignant je prends cet exemple on
pourrait en en prendre d'autres et on
revient sur est-ce que les les communes
évidemment dépendent de l'état oui avec
une erreur qui a été la dernière erreur
la suppression des impôts locaux de la
fiscalité vous vous rendez compte que
dans une commune où vous avez je prends
l'exemple de la commune toujours où je
suis toujours éluz 2/3 de la population
qui ne paye pas d'impôt ça veut dire que
deux habitants sur trois sont
complètement déconnectés entre le
service que leur collectivité leur rend
en permanence l'entretien l'éclairage
public fait que que l'école tourne et
ils n'ont pas de effectivement de lien
de fiscalité mais est-ce qu'il faut
créer un nouvel impôt local est-ce qu'il
faut créer un impôt de résidence puisque
c'est ça qui a été évoqué à un moment
donné en tout cas sur le lien de l'État
vis-à-vis des collectivités il faut que
les dotations soient Sujit à évidemment
l'inflation voilà ça fait partie des des
des vrais sujets que les mères entendent
parce qu'ils font ils sont évidemment
sous pression avec la hausse de
l'énergie euh ce qui a été voté pour
rémunérer le point des fonctionnaires
enfin 35 % donc à un moment donné très
bien il nous faut des personnels de
qualité sur les territoires et donc il
faut les rémunérer en conséquence mais
en face il faut que l'état donne les
moyens aux collectivités de le faire
merci Bruno Belin merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure